Arianne my famous brother Jackie Burke
now the kids kid we have one kid she's
an adult now she's getting married I
thought she was a day you say lesbian
got a possible gig no I have to do a
children's birthday party
do you want a job or you want to be an S
do I have to choose let's talk about
this apportion of a town you live it's
fair to say me and you do it you type in
me that how many hours did you get on me
- my dad used to love your TV show we've
watched every episode always nice to
meet a fan well we just said the one TV
this is the worst thing ever just a
bunch of Olives Hey look are you free
tonight
what like a date or it'll be just an
appointment I'm not sleeping with you I
don't know what you're after
look you had a terrible day you just
said it let me take you to a place you
might have a nice time it's good
adorable when celebrities bring their
boogers - the dog works in the crowd
after everything I've done for you I was
there for you when you were starting out
as a young man
that was amazing I feel like I'm high do
you come up with all that on the spot
sometimes yeah
that was good are you are you free on
Sunday I have a wedding to go to my
niece's wedding you could be my wingman
we have a few laughs we don't want it to
become a thing it's an honor being here
to celebrate Brittany and Frankie's
wedding can i address the 800-pound
gorilla in the room flow what have you
done to my poor little brother he was
six feet tall when you got married this
is no life brother of yours I don't know
why you're yelling at him who are you
with you no one to wear dress don't
comment up my channel I want to know
what your expectations are here my
expectations when you look at my
daughter and the way she looking at you
I'm not looking at him what are you
talking about you have three offers for
appearances what's it gonna be well the
big shot they want you nagisa's in your
crown you're a dancer yeah come sit on
my lap I'll spin you around like a dream
your viral again over three million
views and eight hours and it is still
climbing you are on Kimmel you're on
Fallon
Thank You Burke
[Applause]
you